hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and sunscreen nerd
today i'm going to be talking about one
of the questions i always get asked
about sunscreen
you put it on in the morning and then
you put your makeup on top and then
you're meant to reapply it every two
hours
so how are you meant to do this without
messing up your makeup
and do you really need to reapply that
often
so that's what we're talking about today
if you like nerding out about beauty
you can click the thumbs up subscribe
and click the notification bell so you
don't miss any videos
why do we need to reapply sunscreen if
you look on your sunscreen packaging
usually on the back it'll say something
like
reapply every two hours the reason is
that sunscreen gets less effective over
time
there are a few reasons for this firstly
sunscreen comes off if you brush against
it with your hair your hands your
clothes
less sunscreen means less protection the
second reason is that when you first
apply sunscreen
it forms an even continuous layer on
your skin but
over time this layer becomes less and
less even it starts breaking up and
clumping up
this is because of things like oil
coming out of your skin any sweat
and also just moving your face around
this isn't sunscreen but it's foundation
which is another product that's meant to
stay on your skin for as long as
possible in an even layer
so it uses a lot of the same
technologies you can see that it clumps
up and moves around and migrates into
pores over time
you can also see this on my video on
foundation clumping
the sunscreen film also gets thinner
because it starts evaporating and
absorbing into your skin
the last reason is the one that people
mostly talk about
and that is some sunscreen filters get
less effective over time as they absorb
more uv
this is called photoinstability and it
only actually applies to some of the
older chemical filters
sunscreens these days are usually
formulated to be photostable
so they'll use some of the newer
chemical filters that are photostable
or they'll use mineral filters or
they'll use special
technologies that make the photo-
unstable filters stable enough that
it's not really a big worry that means
that they won't have this specific
problem
but the first two issues still apply so
they still do get
less effective over time so at the start
when you apply your sunscreen that's
when your sunscreen is most effective
and then over time it gets less and less
effective
but how much less are we talking about?
unfortunately there's not that much info
on how long sunscreen lasts on your skin
if you aren't moving around that much
i've only managed to find one study
directly on this topic
20 people applied sunscreen with a
special dye in it so that the
researchers could photograph them every
two hours and track where that sunscreen
went
they didn't use any other products on
their face and they were allowed outside
for up to an hour
here's a graph of what happened on
average after two hours there was 16%
less sunscreen, by four hours it dropped
by another seven percent
and by eight hours it was another four
and a half percent less
after eight hours there was a total of
almost thirty percent less dye which
means around
thirty percent less sunscreen coverage
we can't confidently say that these
results apply for every sunscreen
because we know that different
sunscreens will last for different
amounts of time
so for example if you have a water
resistant sunscreen that tends to last
better on your skin
if you're using chemical sunscreen
filters these tend to absorb a little
bit into the top layers of your skin
and stay around for longer but it means
that there's probably still a
significant amount of sunscreen left on
your skin
at the end of the day if you don't move
around that much for most sunscreens
as an indication if you take 30% away
from spf 50
you get spf 35 spf 30 becomes spf 21 and
spf 15 becomes spf 10.
so the higher the spf you start with the
more likely it is that you'll have a
high amount left at the end of the day
but is this protection enough like i
said in my video on wearing sunscreen
indoors
how much protection you need depends on
how much uv you're exposed to
and how concerned you are about the
effects of uv the main concerns for most
people
are skin cancer wrinkles and
hyperpigmentation
so for a lot of people on most days if
you're not getting a lot of sun and
you're not doing a lot of physical
activity you're not running around
you're not swimming
then the amount that you apply in the
morning is probably going to be enough
but if you're doing a bit more then
you'll probably want to reapply your
sunscreen
so how do we do it if you're reapplying
your sunscreen on top of your makeup
then you'll either have to mess up your
sunscreen or apply less sunscreen or
apply a less even layer
there isn't really a way to avoid this
compromise unfortunately
so i've divided my approach to
reapplying sunscreen into three main
situations that work for me
if i'm not going to get much sun so i go
to work in the morning i get most of my
indirect exposure in the first two
hours and then i come home at night in
the dark
then i don't reapply and i rely on the
sunscreen that i applied in the morning
to get me through
i also avoid walking in the sun so
nothing too extreme
i'll walk on the shady side of the
street i'll sit away from the window on
the train
this is most days and i found that for
me with my skin type my sun exposure
situation and the sunscreens i'm using
my freckles are lightening my
hyperpigmentation goes away quickly
and so i take that as a sign that i'm
doing enough i've done a video on my
favorite sunscreens which i'll link
below if you want to find out more about
those
let's go to the other extreme with lots
and lots of sun
so let's say i go have breakfast with a
friend in the morning and then we go on
a four-hour walk around a lot of nice
beaches i'm going to get tons of sun
exposure i'm probably going to be
sweating a bit
and i really should be reapplying my
sunscreen every two hours
because i'll get sunburned in that case
i put on water resistant sunscreen and
then put on very very simple makeup
so maybe a tinted moisturizer and some
blush or maybe just concealer in the key
areas
then every two hours i'll reapply that
water resistant sunscreen and maybe
touch up the makeup if i feel like i
need it
i'm not going to bother wearing a lot of
heavy blush or contour or highlighter
because
i need those to stay in specific areas
of my face and if i'm reapplying
sunscreen every two hours that's just
not going to happen
when you're reapplying sunscreen you
don't have to cleanse properly or
anything
you can just reapply it on top if you do
have a bit of dirt then you might want
to wipe it off with a makeup wipe or
something
so you don't end up just exfoliating
your face while you're putting on
sunscreen
i'll also wear a hat and sunglasses and
long-sleeve clothes
and i'll be reapplying sunscreen on my
body as well then there's the in between
situation which i think is the one that
most people care about
this is when you want your makeup to
look pretty good but at the same time
you want to get a decent amount of sun
protection
say i'm working in the office but i want
to take a nice long walk at lunch
and i'm going home on the train while
the sun is coming in horizontally
through the windows
in this situation i'll have my standard
sunscreen
and makeup that i've applied in the
morning but i want to reapply sunscreen
on top of that makeup
the most important thing to remember in
this situation is that the amount of
protection you get
scales with the amount of sunscreening
product you apply
on average this is pretty much linear so
if you apply
half the amount of product you get half
the amount of protection if you apply a
quarter
you'll get around a quarter so it's a
matter of getting as much sunscreen on
your face as possible in an even layer
while also not disturbing your makeup
that much
so let's talk about the sorts of
products we can use for reapplication
first off there probably isn't that much
protection in your foundation
in a 2006 study they found that on
average people applied around
0.54 grams of liquid foundation on their
face
they found that there was a lot of
variation and i
actually only apply about 0.2 grams of
foundation
so for that average 0.54 grams of
foundation on
a 400 square centimeter face you'll get
these actual spfs
while for 0.2 grams of foundation you'll get
this level of protection
depending on the labeled spf powders are
even worse
there was a study that was done in the
80s on 10 000 US women
and they found that the average
application of face powder was 85
milligrams
even with an spf 50 powder that gives
you only
spf 5.5 now there's tons of variation
with different products and different
people's application
so i actually emailed a bunch of powder
sunscreen companies to ask if they had
any data on
the amount of protection you'd expect
given a typical application of powder
the answers i got back were really
variable and as much as i want powder
sunscreen to be a thing
because it's so convenient and so easy i
just didn't really find the data
convincing
overall it just seems really unlikely
that you're going to get
enough powder on your face reliably
every time to get an even continuous
layer that you need for
any sort of significant protection even
as a top up method
the most promising data i got was from
colorescience
their specially treated powder is meant
to stick to skin better
and it's 80 minutes water resistant
which means that they got people to sit
in a jacuzzi
for four sessions of 20 minutes with
that powder on their skin
and at the end they came out and tested
that patch of skin and they found that
it still had spf 50
which is really impressive they actually
measured the amount of powder left on
the skin afterwards and
on average it was 0.542 milligrams per
square centimeter
this probably doesn't happen with most
powders that average 85 milligram
application
is less than half of this so i was
pretty impressed
i think their sunscreen powder also
works particularly well
because they have a really high amount
of active ingredients in it
the bad news is that this result comes
from a standard water resistance test
and it's pretty unrealistic when it
comes to a powder so they put two
milligrams per square centimeter of
powder on the skin
pat it out into an even layer leave it
for 15 minutes and then do the water
test
even if we assume that all of that extra
powder that didn't stick on the skin
wasn't necessary
that 0.542 milligrams per square
centimeter still works out to be 0.22
grams for your full face
which is quite a lot to get that much
product out you have to swirl the brush
on your face for a full minute
while priming the brush four times in
our new standard unit for time that is
six happy birthdays
which i think is pretty unrealistic
especially because the instructions
don't tell you specifically how many
times you need to prime the brush
plus with powder sunscreens a lot of
them come in really small pack sizes
like seven and a half grams six grams
even 2.5 grams and so that adds up
really quickly
i think as far as powders go
colorescience is probably your best bet
especially because it's water resistant
and i think this goes for most water
resistant powders
they are going to be more reliable
because they go through that water
resistance test
before their spf is re-measured but i do
think that
other formats for reapplication are
going to be more reliable
they're going to be more likely to give
you the protection you want
so there's only really two options that
i think are reasonable that i've come
across so far
firstly spray sunscreens these are
relatively thin sprays that you can
spray over your face
i think in terms of the evenness of
coverage spray sunscreens
can perform better than cream sunscreens
that's because they have a really low
viscosity they're really runny and so
they can get into the valleys of your
skin better than creams can
this is spraying from 20 centimeters
away and even though there's droplets i
think if you apply a few layers you can
get pretty
even coverage again one of the big
issues is how much you end up applying
it's really easy to underapply if you just
mist it on casually
i recommend that you do a bunch of thin
layers and letting it dry in between so
that it doesn't build up and run your
makeup down your face
you can spray your spray into a quarter
teaspoon measure to see how many sprays
you need to get a reasonable amount of
sunscreen
with these three sprays i found that i
needed between four and nine sprays to
get a quarter teaspoon amount
i recommend checking this yourself with
your own spray there's also an issue
with aerosol sunscreens
these are the ones that come in a
pressurized can and you just hold down
the nozzle and it keeps spraying
this is actually pretty rare for a face
sunscreen most of them i found aren't
pumps
a test in choice magazine to which i am
a proud subscriber
found that for aerosol sunscreens about
40 to 60%
of it was actually propellant aerosol
spray sunscreens are tested without the
propellant so that means you would
actually have to spray for a lot longer
to get the protection you think you're
getting
a few tips for using spray sunscreens
try not to inhale it because that's not
good for you
so i recommend holding your breath
applying it and then walking a couple of
steps
before breathing again also be really
careful when you're applying outdoors
because if you just spray it on your
face
it might blow into your eyes or just
blow away the other option that i think
is really good
is if you just reapply your regular
sunscreen lotion over your makeup with a
cushion puff
james and robert welsh recently did a
video about reapplying sunscreen over
makeup
and they recommended cushion compacts as
a good compromise between getting enough
sunscreen
and not messing up your makeup but one
of the problems with these
is that most of these products have
minerals in them and that can give a
white cast
so what i prefer doing is using the
cushion applicator with
a regular sunscreen lotion so this
technique has been around in the asian
skincare community for years
some people actually buy an empty
cushion container and put the sunscreen
in it so this is what it looks like
something like this where you've got
like the little applicator on top
and then underneath you have the
foundation in this case but you can put
like sunscreen there
i don't think it's necessary though you
can just use the cushion applicator so
the little
thing on top and just use your regular
lotion on like the back of your hand
these applicators are really really
cheap online you shouldn't pay more than
a couple of dollars for one i really
like these because they are really
thin so they're easy to carry around
they also don't soak up as much
sunscreen which is important because
remember the amount matters a lot when
you're talking about sunscreen
you can also fold these so that you can
get it into like tight areas around your
nose
i find that this technique works best
with like a lightweight silicone-based
sunscreen so i'm using this one Klairs
soft airy uv essence
the hardest bit is not transferring
colored makeup onto the areas that are
skin colored on your face
so i recommend starting with the skin
coloured bits and then moving on to
like the blush at the end after you do
it you can also
touch up your makeup and make yourself
look a little bit more presentable if
something messed up
alright so put on a decent amount of
sunscreen on the back of your hand
so you pat a little bit into your sponge
and then you pat it onto your face
so if you're wearing lipstick it's
probably a good idea to like do this
also check if your applicator has
lipstick on it so you don't like stamp
it everywhere
and then you can pause and let that dry
and then put on another layer on like
the skin color bits
and then move on to the colored bits
also check your sponge every once in a
while to make sure it's not too
pink so yeah you can aim it
appropriately and you're not just
stamping random stuff on yourself
i find that in terms of transfer it's
actually not too bad yeah there's a
little bit of pink there it's not too
bad
so yeah that is pretty much all applied
i have a tiny bit left on my
on my hands so i'm just gonna put that
into some of the areas i care about the
most so
top of the cheeks
the nose
so yeah that works pretty well um my
makeup
mostly looks good
i am now missing a little bit of
concealer here so the concealer got
moved
so i would just go in with the concealer
and blot that out again
i don't think it's really possible to
reapply it over your eye shadow without
ruining it so i guess
if this is happening on a day where
you're expecting it then just
don't wear dark eyeshadow or just make
sure you reapply your eyeshadow
afterwards
i filmed this part before i did the
sunscreen reapplication part just in
case it went
horribly badly whatever reapplication
method you're using
you should always check to make sure
that your ingredients are compatible
with each other
some ingredients can break down others
the impact is probably pretty
low but there's a bit more in my ebook
sample chapter if you're interested
also remember that it's not going to be
perfect so make sure you do other sun
projection things so wear a hat
wear sunglasses wear long-sleeve shirts
and try to stay in the shade
or when in doubt just go with the full
reapplication if you have a really good
sunscreen reapplication hack that i
haven't mentioned
make sure you share it with everyone in
the comments i hope you enjoyed this
video give it a like if you like
subscribe click the bell
you can also follow me on instagram and
check out my blog see you next time for
more nerdy beauty